there are so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves this is the kimchi Chic
Beauty Pearl gone wild pressed Shimmer
highlighter this highlighter is so
stunning in the pan it's like this
iridescent pearl color that shifts to
Blue there's a lot of glitter in this
which can look chunky or make your skin
look textured but this actually went on
beautifully the glow it gives is unreal
and that blue sparkle adds a little
something special it's not going to be
for everyone especially if you hate
glitter but this formula is so pretty
and I really want more colors Patrick
tall released these major Skin Creme
foundation and finishing powder Duos I
love the packaging on this especially
this little flap to protect the
foundation from the powder I went in
with my foundation brush first and wow
this is full coverage and a little goes
a long way I did my entire face with
just one dip into the pan I went over
that with a sponge to pick up excess
product I wouldn't say the Finish is
super skin like it definitely looks and
feels like you're wearing Foundation but
for something this full coverage it
doesn't look cakey to me it's also a
more dewy finish which I think helps
these are the Uma Beauty black magic
hypnotic impact High shine lipsticks I
am so into shiny lipstick formulas these
days formula aside though these
lipsticks are gorgeous the embossing the
glitter I could not stop staring at them
they look just as beautiful on the lips
this formula is literally a lip gloss in
lipstick form so you get the shine and
you get that moisturizing feeling the
glitter is an overspray so they don't
look glittery on the lips but I love
these this is the Merit bronze bomb and
it's supposedly the easiest bronzer ever
it's definitely the easiest bronzer I
think I've ever used it takes little to
no effort to blend this out and it
didn't break up the product I already
had on I was worried the shade I got was
too light but I think it actually turned
out okay it is buildable I just wish the
color wasn't so sheer other than that I
like this I'm seeing transfer proof
bullet lipsticks pop up a lot more
lately this one is the Nars power matte
lipstick it has a really amazing color
payoff this can definitely be a one
swipe lipstick the texture is so unique
the best way I can describe it is that
it kind of feels like the Nars soft
matte packaging on its products but on
your lips it's this soft powdery
comfortable kind of mat that felt really
nice on the lips and it is transfer
proof so I highly recommend this this is
the REM Beauty space shape brow gel what
really drew me into this product was the
applicator I've never seen one like this
before with a little doe foot on one
side and a comb on the other it was
really easy to use and I like how it
distributed the product the actual brow
gel is nice it did what it had to do and
it didn't leave my brows feeling crunchy
as much as I like the applicator though
I don't feel like the formula is
anything special KVD has reformulated
its iconic liquid lipstick so I picked
up a few Shades to try just like
everybody else I was very big into the
shade Lolita back in the day so I had to
get queen of poisons which is its new
name I'm gonna be honest I can't really
tell much of a difference between this
formula and the old one I think it maybe
feels a little more lightweight but it
still feels like I'm wearing a slightly
drying liquid lipstick I do really like
the colors I got but this bright orange
was pretty patchy I actually remember
having the same problem with the
brighter colors in the old formula too
so that's not great I also don't like
this new packaging the wand is so
weirdly long I don't know if you can
tell but it was kind of hard to control
when I was applying I have been dying to
try these versed mood lighting
luminizing glow drops for a while people
say that this is another Flawless filter
dupe it does give a really beautiful
glow to the skin but there's not really
any coverage to it so I wouldn't call
this a dupe exactly it's like Flawless
filters more natural little sister it
has a lot of great skincare ingredients
that made my skin feel really nice and
hydrated I actually preferred the drops
under my Foundation rather than on their
own but I like these a lot
thank you